[Music]
patronage X the sequel for the beloved
suspense horror suspense movie I tried
to do this whole grand intro and then I
fumbled it so I'm gonna have some tea
right now calm down a little bit change
the mood
that's called winters cup I believe in
its boy it's delicious anyhow
the sequel to The Strangers is finally
at the battery's flash and right you
know what we're gonna start this again
that's better
all right guys the sequel to The
Strangers is here I quite enjoyed the
first strangers movie I saw it after it
was in the theaters I saw it on video
and you know I liked it I thought it was
well-crafted I appreciated it a lot I
don't necessarily like adore that movie
but I did think it was really intense it
had a really sparse and kind of tone to
it and I thought the acting was good I
forget who the who the male lead was but
uh you know Liv Tyler and her husband
character I like the conceit of that
movie I do understand some of the
complaints you know cuz there's it does
have some horror movie or stuff but this
is an execution of style and suspense
intention and scariness I thought I
thought it was great so I'm curious
about the sequel I don't think it needs
one but I also don't think a sequel
could hurt it in any way and I can see
how you would do this again so alright
litter let's check it out
the fizz silly like that this place
seems empty I think everybody leaves
after it's nice right
[Music]
oh no it's our home I think you have the
wrong trailer
[Music]
oh he's back back
[Music]
what oh man
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but
[Music]
Oh saris yeah
[Music]
you know what man think thank you Joe
Blow movie trailer you know I'm not even
gonna lie I mean yeah to a certain
degree I heard they were making a
stranger sequel and I was like oh I'm
worried just because I don't think bryan
bertino the original folks came back to
to make this movie which you know it's
been a while since the original film
came out was almost 10 years now
I did really enjoy the original so yeah
bryan bertino wrote and directed that
and so this is a different writer and a
different director now and I had some
things to be skeptical about going into
this and at least as far as trailers go
I didn't see the first trailer for this
but based off this this looks like a
blast man I mean I love the cast or at
least the look of the cast Christina
Hendricks is my girl you know I got a I
got a huge crush on her and they all
looked familiar to me I don't I don't
think I know necessarily all these
people which is a good thing for a movie
like this and I like this sort of the
most notable name in the movie is is
Christina Hendricks so that's kinda like
the first was like Liv Tyler is the the
main name I remember from the first one
and I loved her and like I'm psyched
that Christina Hendricks decided to do
this movie that's just a meeting but I
mean she looks like she's giving it her
all and about partway through like I
like the way this trailer built up it's
like it was jumping me back into the
familiar set up of like oh here's a
couple and they're coming back from
something they're getting into it
someplace secluded and quiet for the
night and then they're gonna be
terrorized by the strangers and then the
way it builds over ties it's like it was
nice to jump back into that familiar
territory than the way it built up
introducing like okay there are other
people involved now there are these kids
and there's this whole these aesthetic
this attitude that comes in through the
second half of the trailer I mean this
made it look a lot more fun and like
there was a lot more like winking at the
camera than the first one because the
first strangers I remember being very
stark and being very you know gritty in
a way it had a very grim sort of
foreboding essence and like the couple
the movies about is is having a rough
night anyway so there's a lot of like
emotion
katharsis to that movie and this one
looks like they're making I like that
they decided to jump me back in with
what's familiar then introduce a new
element the colors and the eighties
lights and stuff and then up the may
have move it all because like the main
thing I got from this trailer was mayhem
and you know they're making a sequel and
one of the ways to do that effectively
at least based on a simple premise like
this because like The Strangers you
don't really need to continue the story
so much as check back in on the
strangers in the next spot and see how
that next one goes down so as long as
this movie is taught and you know a Mike
clever I think this could be really fun
so I'm really looking forward to this
this trailer was just so fun to watch
I'm gonna watch it again after I stopped
recording here and it comes out March
9th count me in patreon in jak nation so
uh if you guys got any thoughts leave
them down in the comment box and hey any
more horror movie trailer suggestions or
anything like that send them our way and
I'll try and get them up to that get
them up on here anyhow thanks for
watching